- The Negro Leagues were a benefactor of
World War II in a secondary way.
The war broadened the mindset
and opened up an opportunity for
white Americans to see that
perhaps we need to make
the field level here.
- The major leagues were
supposed to be the best.
But then the major league teams
would get beaten by a team
that had all Black people on it,
people that are supposed to be inferior.
- They knew they had
to break that barrier.
- Newspapers and newspaper writers,
very important,
because they were always
telling the story.
Especially Black publications.
- They were responsible for
documenting this history
that you didn't read about,
hear about in national news.
It was really in our Black newspaper.
And one of those I wanna
salute is Sam Lacy.
- Sam Lacy is, outside of my father,
the biggest influence in my life.
- I think one of the most important
journalists in the annals of
American journalistic history.
- He's in the National
Baseball Hall of Fame's
writers' wing.
He was at every major
sporting event in America.
- He became the voice of Black baseball.
- Sam had a unique writing style.
- You couldn't look past the truth
that was in Sam Lacy's stories.
- One of his quotes was,
"All men are created equal,
but some men are created
more equal than others."
And that was his definition
of white privilege.
- Sam Lacy was very
instrumental in getting
Major League Baseball to integrate.
He had several conversations
in meeting with Clark Griffith,
the owner of the Washington Senators.
According to Sam, many of those meetings
did not go very well.
There were a lot of promises made.
None were ever kept.
- Clark Griffith made so much money
from renting his stadium
to the Homestead Grays
that a lot of these owners
were against integration
because they knew if
Black players were playing
for white Major League Baseball teams
and there were no more Negro league games,
then they would lose
that significant chunk
of revenue that they'd been earning.
- But Sam was persistent,
and he wrote a lot of articles
challenging Clark Griffith to uphold
his commitment to integrate the game.
- There was Kenesaw Mountain Landis,
who was the commissioner of
Major League Baseball,
was very vocal in his stance
that as long as he was commissioner,
there was never going to be
a Black man playing in the major leagues.
- In my opinion, one of the most
racist men in baseball history.
- He's on record telling Rube Foster that,
"You give our league a black eye
when your teams beat our teams!"
- He had an opportunity
to fix the game early,
but he refused to accept
the responsibility, and the game was
not repaired until he died in 1944.
- Happy Chandler becomes
the next commissioner.
And Happy Chandler opens the door
for Jackie Robinson to become the
first Black player to
play in the major leagues
in Major League Baseball's
organized history.
- When we talk about Branch Rickey
signing Jackie Robinson
and integrating Major League Baseball,
he pushed for integration
in a way that didn't honor the
desires and the needs of
everyone else around him.
- Kansas City Monarchs
received zero dollars.
They got nothing for Jackie Robinson.
- October of 1945, Jackie's
deal was announced.
And spring of '46, Branch Rickey signed
other players in addition
to Jackie Robinson.
Branch Rickey is in their backyard.
He is continuing to steal players,
without honoring the Negro leagues,
without honoring their contracts.
And the Negro National League owners
were absolutely livid.
He essentially put the Negro league owners
between a rock and a poorhouse.
- There's no way
that the other owners
can stand up and protest
what every Black baseball fan
in America had been waiting,
and that was for a Black man
to play in the major leagues.
Effa Manley is the most important female
in baseball history,
Black or white.
She's the first woman to be inducted into
the National Baseball Hall of Fame.
- She was the Queen of the Negro Leagues.
- Effa married Abe Manley,
and Abe was a huge baseball fan.
So, in 1935 he purchased
the Newark Eagles.
From the very beginning, he relied on her
to kind of run the
business side of things.
As co-owner, Effa pretty
much did everything
except perhaps player scouting.
But she handled player
contracts and negotiations.
She scheduled games.
She bought uniforms and equipment.
Perhaps most importantly,
she was responsible for public relations
and community relations.
She was constantly trying
to figure out a way
to use her platform with this team
to give back to this community.
- As they integrated the
major leagues, Effa held out.
- I think Effa knew just as well
as all the other owners knew
that baseball's integration was going
to kill the Negro leagues.
- Branch Rickey,
not too long after Jackie Robinson,
comes calling for Monte Irvin.
- Monte Irvin was a superstar player.
Well, Effa Manley essentially refused
to allow him to be signed by
the Brooklyn Dodgers
without it being contested.
- She felt like,
"I have contracts on these men.
And if you want them, you will pay me."
She was criticized by the Black press
for hindering integration,
but she stood her ground.
- Effa always knew she was going to do
whatever she had to do to make sure
that he had an opportunity to play
Major League Baseball.
So, she ended up negotiating
with the owners of
the New York Giants.
They agreed to buy his
contract for $5,000.
Again, far less than what
he was actually worth.
- So, essentially Jackie's stolen,
but she got compensated for people like
Don Newcombe,
Larry Doby.
- Her stance and fighting for compensation
for her players is what essentially opened
this up for other Negro league owners
to at least start getting paid
for players who they would then sell
to the major leagues.
But I think all the owners
at that point in time realized
that the handwriting was on the wall.
It wasn't a matter of if
the Negro leagues were going to fold.
It was simply a matter of
when they were going to fold.